get your salts get your limes it's time
to celebrate national tequila day now
sunday is the big day and chef israel
castro from lanetta in downtown
summerlin is here to help us celebrate
good to see you buddy so good just
always great to have you on the show
thank you thank you so what are you guys
doing on sunday what's the big party on
so we have a tequila dinner we have four
courses and we are going to pair with
tequila with don julio um it's going to
be a 1942 don julio cetenta don julia
negro so it's going to be really fun now
are there different types of tequilas oh
yes we're going to actually have the
anejo tequila we have a cristalino and
also an extranejo so they're gonna be
different and you're gonna pair them up
with different different dishes
different dishes i love it over there
it's awesome what do you guys have what
do you have here
this is actually gonna be our first dish
this is our representation of bread and
butter so we actually did a tequila
infused in bone marrow butter with black
salt and then we pressed some herbs in
the tortillas which we have some herbs
like ojazantas cilantro
oregano and rosemary
it looks so good it smells delicious
lanetta what is the meaning of the
restaurant
is uh the truth like like something
legit like it's
real it's the real deal over there the
real deal can we okay what do you have
here you poured some tequila what do you
have so this is actually my favorite
tequila we have some tequila first thing
to start cooking that's the way to do it
okay all right so this
is one of my favorites please
just have that you want a training wheel
right here sure i need to train all
right this fernandez needs to train
black
yeah sure why not
yeah
and then
there you go
you see if you zoom in there's gonna be
hair going on my chest in just a second
that is good my friend is delicious i'm
lit okay what are we doing what are we
making so right here um all it is i have
some uh chilis here
some sauteed chilies and the purpose of
this like i said this is a
representation of our bread and butter
so have a
tortilla and spread some of this please
right here you need to spread some of
this on here yeah grab a piece hold on
and how do people make reservations we
just show up
they can go online
you like spicy sure let's go spicy all
right spicy and the black pepper what
kind of is this pepper extra special
which one the pepper you put on that one
it's not pepperoni that one it's
actually a salt but it's a little kick
in it
there you go look at this this one this
might be a little spicy but you can do
it like that here this one yeah that
that's mine okay thank you
i love the butter
wow that is good isn't it dark amazing
well i'm spawning okay welcome well back
to our shot of tequila mine's this one
right here yes
but i gotta be honest
i did drink it a little bit
that's fine i hate jeff put water in
mine
it's still good though
thanks a little bit i can't wait to
shout out to tequila on tv
so good chef thank you so much for
joining me happy national tequila day
thank you
the website for people to join me the
website's just going on lanetta online
beautiful thank you so much
rocky you're not rocky jillian i said it
over to you you much tequila you forgot
my name